[Music]
[Applause]
I was the CIA director we lied we
cheated we sneak home stole it's like we
had with entire entire training courses
it it reminds you of the the glory of
the American experiment that's a I don't
know that just that makes me feel kind
of off I don't like that regardless
where's poppy Oh Baba trope put Bush
part of the game
[Music]
perhaps except for Americans people all
over the world have no illusions about
what the states have been doing in
foreign relations cheating and
threatening
there is nothing uglier than these high
ranked character saying that he is a
thief and so on and the people turn a
blind eye to that
[Music]
the American experiment is a lot of
massacre a lot of war and voila there
you go
[Music]
how to manipulate markets I think it has
to be why not
it's sort of an American concept that
they must always win
oh gosh that's what a bizarre thing to
say that glory of the American
experiment what to lie and cheat no I
did it but I can't figure most of the
things that they say out anyway
[Music]
you